[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator TV
and broadcast on Thursday 21st of
September I'm Cindy Yu The Spectators
assistant editor and your host this week
coming up on the show
has the real migrant crisis Only Just
Begun this week saw 12 000 migrants
arrive on the island of lampedusa
journalist Christopher Caldwell takes a
look at how far this crisis can unravel
in our cover article this week he and
Douglas Murray join me on the shame
you turning on net zero this week the
Prime Minister has announced several
delays to previous deadlines saying that
he wants to help voters struggling with
their cost of living but is this good
policy I'll be speaking to our political
editor Katie bulls and our political
correspondent James Hill Australia is
voting on The Voice in a few weeks time
now is not a new reality TV show but a
deeply controversial constitutional
question going to the heart of how
Australia was born is it what the people
want I'll be speaking to Australian
lawyer and writer Helen Dale
and finally 125 000 Hong Kong Chinese
have arrived in Britain in the last two
years yet this massive wave of migration
is barely commented on why not I look at
the issue in an article for the magazine
this week and on the show I'll be joined
by Reverend Dave ho young whose church
is settling in new arrivals in Leeds and
Simon chain a former political activist
in Hong Kong who sought asylum in the UK
in 2020 and has since worked to set up
the organization Hong kongers in Britain
before we get going if you like
spectator TV do subscribe to our YouTube
channel thousands are joining our
Channel every week and you should be one
of them just click the Subscribe button
at the bottom of this video and tap the
Bell icon so you never miss an episode
first up in the last week 12 000
migrants arrived on the tiny Italian
island of lampedusa more than doubling
its population in one day as European
leaders Panic it is only just the
beginning for the cover piece this week
Christopher Caldwell takes a look at
what is to come he joins me now along
with our columnist Douglas Murray who
writes in the his column this week about
how little has changed since 2015 the
last time he was in lampedusa
Douglas and Chris welcome to spectator
TV Douglas take us back to 2015 when you
went July panduza um that was at the
beginning of what we now call the
migrant crisis what did you see
that's right I went there for The
Spectator as it happens eight years ago
now
um and at that point the island which
had about 6 000 inhabitants uh was
getting a lot of boats coming uh I think
just at the time when I was there there
were 1200 people in the uh Asylum Center
there they were trying to get the people
straight off as well as fast as possible
off the island up to Sicily into
Mainland Italy and uh this was something
I then ended up seeing in other places
um as Christopher has in you know the
Isle of Les boss in other Islands across
Greece and that summer of course more
than a million people came illegally
into Europe and uh Europe uh buckled
um but was told effectively by its
political leaders that this was a sort
of one-off and I saw then I knew that
that was absolute nonsense what had been
happening on lab producers they've been
happening at a lesser extent for some
years and it was clear that a kind of
corridor had wrote
and I think what we've seen this week
this past week as a demonstration of
that well Chris tell us about what has
happened in the last couple of weeks
because you've written about it in a
cover article this week
well basically you've had a steady
volume of of traffic to lampedusa as as
Douglas says but um over the course of
about
five days
um last week uh uh lampedusa got 11 or
12 000 people which totally overwhelmed
that um that Detention Center in the
middle of the island that Douglas was
talking about and have have actually
overwhelmed public transport and and the
public transport on other Islands as
well and turned it into a bit of a a
political crisis for uh Georgia
Maloney's government Maloney is a is is
a politician who who sort of alarmed a
lot of um uh European journalists when
she came to power a year ago uh uh
because she's descended from the kind of
Mussolini friendly part of the of the
Italian right but in fact it um over the
course of the past year she's ruled in a
very very moderate and I would even say
a center left and pro-european way and
so she's reached a point now where the
main threat to her domestically is from
her actual base from people who don't
believe she's been uh let's say
conservative or or nationalistic enough
and that in turn is sort of kind of uh
it's that is being noticed in other
European countries which are beginning
to have their own immigration
discussions and Chris I want to talk a
little bit more about the political
ramifications in just a second but why
is it that there's been such a huge wave
in the last couple of weeks is it
because of the natural disaster the
flaws that earthquakes has been
happening in North Africa what's is that
being something of a Breaking Point
what's happened
I I don't think it's the um the flood in
Libya although I do think Libya is the
key um Douglas spoke of a of a of a
cordon being breached you know in in
2015 in terms of behavior I think in
this in the case of lampedusa the
important breach of the court and
um came in 2011 uh with the uh with the
the the the the euro-american invasion
of of Libya
um now people had wanted to people were
very impatient with um more America
Muammar Gaddafi there were reasons to be
impatient with him but he had kept the
um the immigration pressures from Africa
pretty well bottled up there's very
little regulation of these these flows
now it's very catches catch can the
Italians have
um they've been in negotiations with
um the Libyan Coast Guard it's it's it's
just very irregular and so so why were
there 11
000 people this week I don't exactly
know but it may just have to do with the
scheduling of the people who are
traveling trafficking these people or
with something going on deeper in in
Africa but
yeah I I think that I I think that it's
the Anarchy in Libya if you had to name
one factor
um the the proximate cause would be the
Anarchy in Libya and the larger cause is
the absolutely unbelievable demographic
growth in Africa and Douglas I saw your
column in this week also on this topic
it was very interesting because you talk
about why politicians haven't managed to
fix this uh in the eight years since you
you went to lampedusa I mean we've had
you know migration has been top of the
agenda for a lot of people and for
political discourse in the in Europe
you've written the book about it you've
got people like Maloney who come into
government on this platform so why can
politicians like her not fix it
well as Chris has said Chris has written
a book about this as well I mean it's
been a long simmering issue in Europe
and I'd argue The Wider West it's same
miss you America is facing at its
Southern border uh modern democratic
nation states seem to find it hard to
defend their borders certainly in Europe
and North America
um the interesting thing is as you
mentioned that the there is serious
public uh worry about this as there is
in Britain with this with the small
boats coming across the channel at keep
breaking records keep breaking records
uh in Britain our politicians say wig
this is our number one priority and
we're gonna deal with it and then they
don't Georgia Maloney's number one
priority says she wants to deal with it
then she does it and and uh the sort of
online no walls and sort of some of the
conspiracy types at this point say aha
she's been completely bought she's
become a shill of the EU and so on I
don't actually have much time for
Maloney she doesn't have very much time
for me either
um she's not my type a politician but it
I was very struck when she came in I
thought okay well there's one thing
she's really going to be tested on and
so far she's failed there she was in
lampedusa this week alongside Ursula Van
de Leiden and once again Maloney is a
Italian Prime Minister saying we are
taking too much strain in Italy the EU
is not doing enough and I think wow how
many years have I heard that for it's
still true but it still has to be said
and the real explanation I think or one
of the explanations that I give him my
caller and I think hasn't been pointed
out enough is look at what has happened
to some of her Rivals look at what
happened to Mateo salvini who was
interior Minister and Deputy Prime
Minister he's technically a sort of Ally
of Maloney's but also of course a rival
salvini actually did manage to slow down
the boats Landing in land producer and
Sicily how did he do it among other
things by simply for bidding them
permission to laugh and that included
NGO ships and this is very important
because it's not just the smuggling
networks in the Mediterranean the
smuggling networks work with some ngos
to test the nation states orders and
there were NGO ships off the coasts of
Italy and and material salvini refused
to allow them to land now what has
happened since uh it's true that the
flow of migrants reduce but salvini has
been twice prosecuted including by an
overwhelming vote in the Italian Senate
to prosecute him for what kidnapping was
the title
the people on the boat by refusing to
allow illegal migrants to land so I give
that example very quickly I'll give
another example ingestoibo who Denmark
was very lucky to have as their
immigration integration minister in 2015
until 2019. ingest toiberg was the the
most important figure to make sure that
Denmark did not make the mistakes Sweden
did in 2015 and taken hundreds of
thousands of people who then couldn't
integrate so Denmark didn't do that
largely because of Angus Freiburg what
is ingest toyberg's reward been for
keeping her country's borders secure she
has been prosecuted in Denmark she was
sentenced to prison for effectively
defending the borders of Denmark she had
to wear an ankle bracelet so when
Maloney or any other European politician
of right or left is looking at this if
you do the wrong thing and you make sure
that you just allow a constant flow of
illegals into your country you will
retire fine you will be on NGO board
you'll be on Bank boards you'll be just
fine if you do the right thing and
enforce your country's orders you are
likely very likely to face the rest of
your life in the courts well Douglas on
that that law fair is clearly incredibly
concerning especially for democratically
elected politicians but you know to
Chris's point about the underlying
causes things like the 2011 military
intervention in Libya you know how much
can these politicians really have fixed
it you know these these suggestions for
example like the Rwanda plan all of
these different policies which sound you
know on paper dramatic but how much can
that really fix what's you know
something of a structural problem here
you know don't you think that actually
by by blame it on warfare actually we're
giving these policies a bit too much
credit maybe they couldn't have fixed it
anyway
well I think I don't see why it's
impossible to enforce the law
I mean reinforce the law on lots of
other things it's extremely difficult to
get to a country like America or Britain
legally
is it so wildly easy to get into it
illegally I'm sorry it is easy everyone
talks about the perilous Journey you
only have to spend a few hours in a boat
it only costs a few thousand dollars
it's very easy you walk straight in and
you've got a hotel and then you'll get a
work permit as well the legal route is
extremely difficult the illegal one has
become easy I'm sorry politicians can
sort that out I don't think it's
something I don't think it's the world's
hardest Rubik's Cube and Chris what do
you think and also on that point about
legal versus illegal routes you know
people often say if you gave them more
legal routes if you could properly
separate those fleeing political
persecution uh fleeing war and famine
from those who are just looking for you
know economic migration then actually
the public will be more on side you know
what about that argument
that's very very hard to do and I and I
you know it was a good there was a good
article in um
in ilfolio which is an Italian uh
newspaper this week by a writer named
John Carlo quenzi and he talked about
this shibboleth that all
uh immigration uh politicians all
politicians who talk about immigration
they say that that the real solution to
this problem is to develop Africa to
give migrants more opportunities in the
places where they are
think that if that were easy to do I
think the private sector would be
looking into ways of of doing it the the
fact is
Europe is where the where you connect to
the global economy there there's not
it's going to be it would take a very
very long time
longer than the the Next Generation to
create such an infrastructure uh uh
abroad even if it were possible you're
talking about building up an economy in
an entire in an entire other continent
which which in in Europe has very few
resources now to to to spend on its own
I just don't see how that is possibly
going to happen so it becomes a question
of actually one hates to talk this way
it becomes a question of defending the
border of just sort of physically
keeping people from Crossing that border
and that's it that is a that is a
military problem that's not a it's not a
a courtroom problem or something you
just have to create physical obstacles
to passing and in that we have a kind of
an underlying
um philosophical problem we have a kind
of our governing classes and generally
this is in in most countries this is as
true of the putatively conservative
party as it is of the putatively
Progressive Party there's a there's an
allergy to thinking of politics this way
as this sort of like uh the use of force
to keep people from doing one thing or
another and there's another dimension to
it which is that the rhetoric
surrounding human rights is very hard to
confine to
the rhetoric of citizenship so human
rights rhetoric tends to work against
Republican rhetoric it tends to you know
it's very hard to sort of like establish
that citizens have these rights and then
to answer the question of well okay if
the people on your street have the right
to walk freely why don't the people in
this other country it's a it's a complex
argument but but until we're clear
but as long as we're not clear on it it
it's very easy to game the system can I
add one thing to that city which is ABS
absolutely agree with what Chris has
said but um the argument that you need
to improve the economies of Africa
before you can solve this problem first
of all I mean it's like just
will it ever happen in anyone's lifetime
who knows are you willing to sacrifice
the future of Europe to that personally
not but secondly it's a fallacy Theresa
May used to say this during the
migration crisis she used to say we need
to work at improving the economies in
the countries people are coming from
flat out wrong you can improve the
economies nice thing to do good thing
for those people that doesn't solve the
migration problem in fact a lot of the
evidence shows if if the lifestyle of
the people in a particular country rises
in Africa slightly you get more migrants
coming to Europe because they have the
means to come to Europe so this is all
built on a set of massive fallacies and
to paraphrase something David goodheart
said some years ago that we in in Europe
in particular but America as well have
made two massive miscalculations that
are generational the first is we have
massively underestimated the number of
people who want to come
and in sub-Saharan Africa alone that is
just a bottomless number of people so we
have massively underestimated the number
of people who want to come into our
countries and we are massively
overestimated our ability to integrate
them it's a joke that the people this is
what I realized when I first was on land
producer it's a joke to think that these
people are going to soon become Milanese
Italians or Florentine Italians and
they're going to meld into the culture
of Dante and Picacho and much more it's
a joke they won't their lives will be
very miserable in Italy they will be in
a criminal underclass gang world where
at best they will be selling illegal
handbags on bridges in Venice and
running from the police when they come
the idea that this is the next
generation of Europeans is for the birds
I don't think that intervention to make
Africa more wealthy is something that
the West should be engaging with and as
Chris is suggested you know in some ways
intervention was the very first problem
in the first place but Douglas where
does that line where do you draw that
line when it comes to integration
because do you think it's a volumes
problem do you think that some cultures
inherently find it difficult to
integrate because in the magazine this
week I also have a piece out talking
about the 125 000 Hong kongers who have
come to the UK in the last two years now
what I find from meeting them is that
they tend to be well 70 of them have
University degrees many of them already
speak English they come having sold
their Hong Kong Flats immediately on the
housing ladder here do you think that
integration is a problem for them too or
what is the what is the difference here
that we're talking about
um there's about three things that
really matter in Immigration uh there is
the speed
there is the numbers and there's the
identity
and that's pretty much it
um if you do if you do a difficult
identity to integrate but you do it
incredibly slowly
you can just about cope
do an identity that's hard to integrate
fast and in large numbers it's not going
to work the interesting case you give of
the whole call is it's got many of these
people apart from as you say they've got
University degrees I'm afraid that the
random flow of people across the
southern border of America or across the
soft underbelly of Europe you're not
dealing with people who are massively
over-educated I'm sorry to say but it's
fact they uh the idea that they speak
the languages of Europe again know and
it's difficult for and it's much more
difficult than it is for somebody from
Hong Kong thirdly people from Hong Kong
as you know certainly I mean many of
them have grown up effectively under a
British system of law among other things
that it's not it so so it's not the
hardest pit to fit into the jigsaw in
the same way there are many people in
America who are in favor of a sort of
lacks immigration policy in America as
compared to Europe because they say well
look it's Hispanics it's they're
Christians almost entirely
um they can fit into our culture
actually a central and southern
Americans don't immediately integrate
into American culture that easily but
it's a better fit than a Muslim Nigerian
trying to fit into France in the 21st
century and again I mean these are just
such obvious things but we've made such
baby steps in recent years of even
acknowledging them that we can't
recognize again speed numbers identity
and the ones people want to speak about
least is identity I mean and Chris just
finally then you know we all know what's
happened to European politics in the
last eight years when this crisis has
not got better it's only got worse are
you writing your piece about the very
many different political shake-ups you
know from Trump to brexit to various
kind of right-wing politicians across
the continent you also write concerning
me that the migrant crisis may only just
be starting that actually this current
wave is going to shake shake European
politics to it cool what do you think is
going to happen from here
well it it just has to do with the size
I think that that of the things that
Douglas was just talking about the key
thing is the size if you got
um if you brought if suddenly one
percent of Florence were made up of of
of migrants it re it probably wouldn't
matter where in the world they were from
over time they could be assimilated but
the numbers in involved particularly
when you go from one side of the
Mediterranean to the other are
extraordinary so this this collapse of
birth rates which we've seen in Europe
probably over the last 50 years you know
it tends to reflect itself in aging it
tends to be camouflaged for a very long
time it's it takes about a couple of
generations before the that you start to
see it in the the rate of population
replacement but we're at that point now
and the European each successive
European generation is about a third
smaller than the last or at least in a
country like like Italy and then in in
Africa you have a situation where the
continent is is just exploding with
population particularly south of the
Sahara you have a you know there were
there were about
200 million people in sub-Saharan Africa
at the end of um you know the colonial
era say in nineteen
sixty and and and by mid-century there's
going to be over two over two billion
that is from now until mid-century
there's going to be a doubling of
population and that means
you know you have a lot of people trying
to fit into an economy that doesn't have
room for them and they're they're very
they're young they're Dynamic they're on
the move and so we're only at the
beginning of that population growth so
so yes it's going to get get worse
before it gets better but Chris if if
our population is shrinking then we do
have space for the main economy
well it's I mean it's just it's not a
question of just what you have space for
I mean it's a question of the the kind
of society you want to have when you
talk about the numbers when you talk
about the numbers these are large enough
numbers to
become the the culture of uh of of
Europe I mean you you you you you want
to you I assume that one wants to
perpetuate the the culture of Europe
rather than just sort of like uh trade
it off for a foreign
such a rich topic for pickings for
another conversation but I'm afraid
we've run out of time there and Douglas
Murray Chris Coldwell thank you so much
don't inspectase TV
next Russian CNAC has been forced to
reiterate his commitment to Net Zero
after a series of government policies
pushing back green targets were leaked
earlier this week its course
consternation among many in Industry
campaign groups and even within his own
party but is it nevertheless good policy
I'll be speaking to our political editor
Katie bulls and our political
correspondent James Hill
James and Katie welcome to spectator TV
now James this story about Net Zero
first came from a leak on Tuesday night
but Richard seem like has since
confirmed his intentions anyway so what
do we know about the plans
yes as you say Cindy I think the way in
which the story first emerged was not
how number 10 implanted on it but there
was this big press conference yesterday
in which Richardson announced that he
was going to be changing some of the
measures the government planned to
introduce uh in order to hit Net Zero
commitments one of which was delaying
the internal combustion engines which
are petrol and diesel cars until 2035.
other was changing way in which uh
boilers at home was going to be rolled
out until 2035 as well and announcing
more cash as well and really I think
that you know this was Richie sunac in
the press conference yesterday in one of
those forums where he really excels
which is taking questions he's always
very good at the detail talking to
people around him they're always
impressed by how um you know they can
he's very good at Martian there's kind
of those granular details and so I think
that there was a lot of excitement
beforehand because this was all the Tory
Civil War and the splits Etc and that
zero divides I think after that press
conference has kind of been quieting
down a little bit but really this is as
Katie writes in this week's magazine I
think about trying to find some issues
which are going to be difference between
uh labor and the tour of the next
election and they've already come out
and criticized for Scenic plan
um Katie is this going to divide Tories
from labor in terms of that dividing
line that you write about as much as it
devised Tories themselves because as
expected you know people like Zach
Goldsmith are not happy about it and
Boris Johnson has also now come out of
the woodwork so it says more of a
problem for Tory's Civil War perspective
I think there's enough division to go
around really
um ultimately it does divide the Tories
to a degree to James's point I think
there was a lot of panic ahead of the
speech because Richie said it was
effectively bounced into moving the
speech forward because of that leak and
therefore they didn't get to do the
framing that they would have liked to do
around it that left a bit of a news
vacuum as number 10 worked out what to
do you had a statement confirming the
report was broadly correct but not much
more and therefore people like Boris
Johnson uh Zach Goldsmith Chris good
were all piled in and started voicing
their concerns the WhatsApp groups blew
up someone you know told me it was a
bloodbath ahead of the speech effect on
the various groups
um however when we're trying to judge
Tory opinion I think that it is not the
case that Zach Goldsmith is a Bellwether
mainstream Tory opinion he is viewed by
his own colleagues as pretty much on the
extreme end of Tory opinion at least
when it comes to Net Zero commitments he
also of course did flirt a few weeks ago
with the idea of voting labor and he
quit as a minister in the department who
is it on the environment it's always
things suggest that he's been unhappy
for some time we could have expected I
think a number 10 did expect him to not
like it
um and therefore I think the bigger
question is are the splits significant
in a way that for example there will be
young legislation but there will be a
vote on one of the measures but is
actually quite complicated in the sense
there has to be a vote because they
haven't even voted on the 2030 Target
and so it's not necessarily going to be
this nice dramatic vote that some people
are thinking but is there enough torian
rest for people to try and cause trouble
for Rich you see like on this issue and
I think on that you know the jewelry is
out I think real really the the question
is
is this policy a sign that Rishi sunak
is working out his electoral campaign
tactics because if you look at list
policy at least as you know alone I
think the sense talking to MPS and AIDS
is that they think it will play better
with I think the base but also the 2019
Coalition whereas the MPS are less happy
today when you speak to them are lows in
those blue wall seats but they had the
lib Dems as the second largest party and
they are worried not so much actually by
the policy shift but the idea that the
way it's being written up and the
perception
um you know which people can debate that
the Tories are moving away from NetZero
and I originally don't keep saying 2015
NetZero is staying but if it becomes you
know Tories scaling down commitments
here and you have other parties led to
Hoover up the votes I think that could
be a problem I also think we're not
actually really going to know on the
polling where this is going for you know
at least a month you might get some
initial reaction I mean when it comes to
the individual as their card delay
delaying that's 2035 the polling is
actually quite positive for the Tories
on it particularly with the voters
they're going for and therefore I think
in terms of Rishi sunx big picture this
is the beginning of him a having some
dividing lines but more what we're going
to hear from that conference with this
idea that he wants to pitch himself as
the leader who will tell the truth who
will not offer easy solutions and so
forth and I think this is probably the
first policy announcement which is going
to fit in with the narrative we're going
to hear more from in the today program
this morning he was talking to Nick
Robertson which we can listen to a bit
of now where was this proposal for the
government to put a tax on meat that you
had to scrap with such a Fanfare yeah
there were a range of things that have
been proposed by lots of different
people forcing people to have seven bins
and other proposals you said you've
scrapped yeah so if you look in if you
look in the environment Act and the
associated consultations that were in
place around 2021 from memory
um there's a very clear statement in
there about moving to consistent
collection for recycling your former
environment said Minister says you're
pretending to Halt frightening proposals
that simply do not exist no I just I
reject that entirely it's all about
politics you're making a series of
claims that aren't true no this is
absolutely about doing what I believe to
be in the long-term interests of the
country Nick Robinson was asking him
about the seven bins idea or the
taxonomy policies that people didn't
really associate with NetZero anyway but
the government has this week said that
they're like scrapping which has led to
a lot of ridicule and do you think that
kind of um backlash has been Justified
politicians always want to send up you
sometimes imagine threats almost so you
know Tony Blair was always great at
doing this like they want to do this we
want to do that dividing lines Etc and
there's always a degree in which sort of
you hype up a threat that being said you
know you look at things like the
environment act 2021 and there were
policy suggestions that you could have
seven bins involved in that you know
look at the climate change committee and
when which they've flirted with the idea
of having uh you know increased taxes on
things like media basis in truth
although it's obviously not like the the
government wasn't going to introduce
until yesterday meet taxes and now just
scrap them but that being said I mean
you get down to a local level but you
know there are councils across England
for instance where there's now debates
about you know should meet be certain
meals Etc like that so it's something
that there's an element of that but I
agree I mean I think that you know big
picture stuff as Casey sort of alludes
to is that we're unliking to see these
are major shift in the polls as a result
of this because I just think that most
people don't know if you look at the
polling about Net Zero and I'm not sure
it's going to be really in itself uh
enough to shift a vote but I think it's
kind of more about distinguishing and
trying to make Rishi xenox seem although
on the side of ordinary people and try
and cause a few headaches for labor who
at the moment I think have really been
trying to mimic the government or every
time they've announced a cast or a
change Etc by going along with it you
saw this with hs2 this week you can also
see how eventually these dividing lines
in an election campaign
um because labor have confirmed that
they would keep the car Target 2030 so
move it back and from where the Tories
are putting it and therefore what you
keep hearing from us you see like
already as you know five thousand ten
thousand fifteen thousand and you know
is that the cost that label want to put
on uh you know households so I think
that it's going to be one of the things
you keep hearing up in the Builder's
election you also take the um policy on
small boats the fact that Kirsten has
now laid out what he wants to do and the
Tories plan to keep going on him for a
return screaming so we are starting to
see better lines be drawn it's just that
these things don't happen overnight in
terms of where you end up to
um it's going to be a slow build but
you've seen I think it's beginning to be
sketched out so is it tricky for labor I
think the labor party is quite divided
on it there are some who think that this
is good for them in the sense something
I wrote about a while ago they will be
able to argue that the tour is almost
the extremists on Net Zero you know both
parties trying to have that Center
ground you just need to debate what the
center ground is
um and and therefore this gives them
fuel to the fire and they think it it
could misfire quite badly particularly
with some of the voter Coalition and for
others do worry it could become a cost
of a living issue and what they don't
want to do is have kissed armor Rachel
because so they are you know punishing
you know voters when it comes to cost
and I think that's where there's a mixed
picture I would say in terms of how good
or bad and I think it's telling that the
main attack at the moment from labor is
fatally just saying Liz trust said this
earlier this week in Her speech on the
economy
um so you know it's actually Liz trust
they've done an inverse of the famous
you know pocket uh poster which the
Tories did of Edmund about a neck of the
sturgeon and they're saying you know
it's actually Liz truss pulling the
strings which I think I love that this
is anyone who like has to actually you
know cover these volunteers I mean I
think I can see what they're doing in a
way I'm sure it's creating some
amusement but the idea of this number 10
pay much attention to what this trust
says I think um is for the birds well
actually geez we can finish on this
trust because she just said she didn't
make that big speech barely in the week
and you are our residents in this trust
expert so tell us you were there what
does she say well she was really
reflected when you were on the mini
budget and I think it's quite
interesting you know some of the debates
around today about sunak's statement and
the climate change Committee involved
from that and the Immunology with the
office of budget responsibility which
obviously the trust government said they
weren't going to have the forecast for
that many budget so I think it's
interesting always looking at what Liz
trusted in government and then operation
often seems to try and do the exact
opposite of that in terms of making sure
to kind of build a consensus plan your
battle pick your battles choose the
right timing Etc
um I think often could take care around
briefings what you're actually going to
do and try and make everything you seem
as really sensible that whereas I think
this trust operation they're very much
Keen to emphasize how radical they were
going to be and do things like the 45p
tax cut so it's interesting comparison
yeah and the overwhelming message would
seem to be it wasn't megov I think that
yeah there was certainly a fair amount
of recrimination going around uh
pointing fingers and obviously of
Interest perhaps with you know the bank
of England and what Bank of England got
wrong ahead of today's uh inflation
announcement but uh yeah there was
certainly um yeah I'm not sure how much
uh Alfred to notice will be taking
number 10 by what uh some of the four
premise comments were yeah still not
much me and Mia Culper
Benz thanks so much
in Australia a referendum is set for the
to amend the country's
if approved the vote would establish an
Aboriginal and Torres Strait Islander
voice a legislative body just for
indigenous people but it's a question
that has torn the country apart
Helendale is a writer and lawyer from
Australia she's with me now
so Helendale welcome to spectator TV
now the concept of a referendum is quite
traumatizing I think for a lot of Brits
now but it seems like Australia is going
through something quite similar can you
tell us about this upcoming referendum
called The Voice
the referendum that we're about to have
on the 14th of October in Australia is
the first referendum the country has had
since 1999 the previous referendum was
on whether Australia would become a
republic and it's failed in all state so
it really went down at a screaming Heap
the referendum this time is to entrench
a voice for Aboriginal and Torres Strait
Islander people in the Constitution now
I perhaps should explain exactly what
the question is that we'll go to the
Australian people what you will see if
you are Australian and you walk into the
polling station and then into the
polling booth on a piece of paper is a
proposed law to alter the Constitution
to recognize the First Peoples of
Australia by establishing an Aboriginal
and Torres Strait Islander voice do you
approve this proposed alteration right
and it has been equated essentially as
establishing a third chamber in the
legislature for Aboriginal voices but
why does that why is that needed are
they not already voters in the in the
Democracy why Jesus said need to be some
kind of ethnic or racial basis for that
kind of representation
what has happened uh and it's perhaps
best to draw an analogy with the
Republic referendum in 1999. the most
powerful argument against the no case in
other words for the to The Republic was
if it ain't broke don't fix it this is
an Australian expression because it's
very true that Australia is a prosperous
orderly well-governed country uh that is
up there with Switzerland and Norway and
ahead of the United States in terms of
income per capita and purchasing power
and wealth per capita it's a very
orderly well-governed country
so the one of the reasons the Republic
referendum failed was that very basic
fact
the difference with the voice argument
is that since Federation in 1901
Aboriginal and Torres Strait Islander
policy from governments of all Stripes
has been a failure so the system is
broken so that is the most powerful
argument for the yes case the most
powerful argument for the no case is the
one that you pointed out that it is
indeed dividing people up and will allow
a certain group of people to cast a
ballot and remember voting is compulsory
in Australia so this is very important
on the basis of their ethnic ancestry
you can't say race because the human
species there is only one race the human
race but you can certainly divide people
up by ancestry as anyone who has ever
taken a 23 and meat test can can testify
so the issue with the voice and this is
why it's so fraught and dividing and to
visit is both claims are true the yes
case claim is true Aboriginal and Torres
Strait Islander policy has been a
terrible multi-gen rational failure in
Australia and the no case is true this
is indeed dividing up the Australian
people on the basis of ethnic ancestry
which is not something that we have done
for a very very long time in this
country
can you talk a little bit about that
failure of uh policy towards the
Aboriginal people what do you mean by
failure
and what have the policies been
oh well the policies have been very very
different over over a hundred years now
since Federation you can't really scoop
up the pre-federation period because
Australia was a separate a lot of
separate colonies each of them which
were really really quite different from
each other Australia is a more intensely
federal policy than the United States
okay you can secede from the Australian
Federation peacefully in a way that you
can't from the United States Federation
they had a civil war over it so the
policy is quite different but since 1901
what has happened is there were policies
of assimilation to try to make
Aborigines as similar to the P to the
various settlers from various Europe
mainly European countries but later from
Southeast Asia there's a very very
significant Chinese population in
Australia
first that was one policy it failed
caused it was an enormous mess
then there were attempts to try to
preserve the distinctive characteristics
of Aboriginal civilization this was a um
hunt together a civilization very very
unusually structured Society uh most
well I'll give you one example most
hunter-gatherers hunter-gatherers
civilizations of which we are aware in
the world are monogamous uh a great
Chief will only have one wife their
Aborigines had a system of gerontocratic
polygamy which is extremely rare it's a
very very unusual social system and it
seems to have been developed and you can
make all your Australian jokes now
because the environment in Australia is
so dangerous older people first men and
then older women need to teach younger
people how to survive in it it is so
dangerous and the the best way I can get
this across to you and you can make
another Aussie joke if you like is the
Indian cobra is the 15th most poisonous
snake in the world the other 14 are in
Australia
and that's why I'm never going to go to
Australia Helen um but actually Helen
what does that actually mean for lives
today for Aboriginal people because I
think here in the UK we have a very
different race history we also have our
own problems with our own ethnic
minorities in terms of how that history
comes out in inequalities today but for
Australia that it does sound like a very
different situation so are we seeing
basically in Australia where aboriginals
are
um you know relatively economically
poorer uh less educated more prone to
Crime what are the actual problems here
that aboriginals feel or some
aboriginals I should say feel like they
need a constitutional voice
the biggest one is a difference in life
expectancy
and the health outcomes for aborigine
Aboriginal and Torres Strait Island the
people particularly Aborigines it's less
bad with Torres Strait Islanders because
Torres Strait Islanders are where
melanesian or our melanesian
civilization so they had already gone
through the Agricultural Revolution so
their society is somewhat different and
they are also as it ethnically
constrained they're in Far North
Queensland and the islands of the Torres
Strait in between far North Queensland
and Papua New Guinea so they're a bit
different in in this characteristic but
Aborigines who are the majority there
are more Aborigines than there are
Torres Strait Islanders just as a matter
of numbers
catastrophically shorter life expectancy
serious problems amongst the youth in
rural areas and remote areas with fetal
alcohol syndrome high crime rates high
unemployment enormous sums of money
shoveled in the direction of Aboriginal
communities none of which seem to do
very much and that that is what is fed
into this and it's why initially
although the the polls are cratering
badly now and it looks like the voice
will fail it will no will win like in
the Republic and it may win at every
state but initially there was 70 public
support for a voice and this is going
back maybe six 12 months and the reason
for that is because of this huge policy
failure over multiple Generations the
expression that will be used in
Australia is the phrase closing the Gap
and when they talk about closing the gap
between Aborigines and everybody else
which is and remember 25 of the
Australian people are born the Seas
Australia is the most Multicultural
Nation on Earth
you know way ahead of the United States
way ahead of the United Kingdom in terms
of ethnic diversity Australia is where
where it is where it's at
so this huge gap closing the Gap in
terms of health outcomes in terms of
employment outcomes and in terms of
incarceration rates
are the three big things that really
really stand out as the Gap that people
want to close on all sides of politics
between
everybody else and Aboriginal people in
particular the Torres Strait Islanders
as I was saying occupy a sort of
intermediate position and they are
culturally really quite different and
perhapsular Society in a free democracy
inequality is okay you know we take that
so as to not live in total equality like
communism or something like that but
Matthew Paris our economists it writes
in this week's magazine that he thinks a
lot of what's motivating both sides of
the debate right now is the notion of
white guilt that actually the white
majority in Australia has some kind of
responsibility for the early years of
taking over the land of the aboriginals
when they first arrived in Australia do
you think that that white guilt is
playing into this debate
it's certainly a large part of the yes
case and it is probably what is
accounting for the the decline in the
support for it initially when it was
first proposed it was proposed by an
Aboriginal fellow a lawyer called Noel
Pearson who is widely respected in
Australia as an extremely able intellect
and legal practitioner really really
gifted guy and he he's admired across
all sides of politics Noel Pearson so
the the support initially was I suspect
a lot of it was a we love Noel Pearson
on all sides of politics because he's
just really really well regarded but
what has happened is you you can't it's
very hard to control everybody if you're
not a political party in promoting a
particular
argument in politics and this is very
much a political argument and so what
has happened is you finished up with
attempts to play on people's guilt the
white people's guilt and the thing is
it's not all white people this is the
difficulty when you've got a country
that is so ethnically diverse you've had
reactions from members of Australia's
ethnic minorities that are quite
unpredictable and are probably not what
the yes case expected Australia has
large numbers of the hakka minority
Malaysian Chinese for example
and one of the reasons why we have so
many Malaysian Chinese in Australia is
because they object to the policies in
their in their country of origin that
favor indigenous malaise over Chinese
malays because Chinese malays occupy a
position in that Society analogous to
Jews in Eastern Europe and Central
Europe before the second world war they
are a market dominant minority and very
successful so they don't like it and so
they have they've responded a lot of
them I have with it I don't know that we
had saw this in Malaysia you don't want
it here and I think the yes case made
the mistake of thinking everybody who's
going to be arguing no is going to be a
white person but that's not been the
case the the people who are arguing no
many of them are aborigines but they are
from the remote community so they're
from very very uh sparsely populated
areas of the country where some of the
Aborigines a significant number of them
still live quite close to a tribal
lifestyle and so that the main leader
um of the no case is and I I can't
actually say a person uh her full
surname jacinta uh najimpira it's a long
Aboriginal name and has a she's a double
barrel with price which is her husband's
name and she's from uh Central Australia
from the from the desert regions she's
been the main leader of the no case and
then the other no arguments that have
tended to be made have often been of the
type well no we ran away from this in
our country and this is why we came to
Australia so when I say it's promoted
division it has promoted division but
it's allowed a lot of sort of guilty
white people to find out what the rest
of Australia is really like because it's
such a diverse country
yes well I guess the referendums really
do show you something about a country
unless we know here in the UK Helendale
thank you so much for joining us
spectator TV
and finally when Britain opened its
doors to the Hong Kong Chinese following
beijing's countdown in 2020 they came
here in their hundreds of thousands but
why do we know so little about what is
one of the biggest migrant groups to
arrive in modern British history for the
magazine this week I write that they
will make as much of a mark on Britain
as a Windrush generation did
joining me now is Reverend Dave ho young
whose church is helping new arrivals in
Leeds to settle in and Simon Chang who
was an activist in Hong Kong and granted
asylum in the UK in 2020. he now runs
the organization Hong kongers in Britain
Simon Chen and Reverend Dave ho young
welcome to spectator TV
Now Dave I want to start with you
because it's really through talking to
you that I first got to cover this
incredible story of Hong Kong migration
to the UK can you tell us about the
welcome sessions that your church has
been putting on
yeah so um our church up in Leeds um has
been doing these these welcome sessions
for uh new arrivals from Hong Kong for
uh probably probably around about 18
months now and we have been working with
a UK charity called Faith action who've
put together some informal English
classes and we were asked to be one of
the uh the kind of um uh churches in in
the in the Yorkshire region he would
kind of roll out this course so we've
been doing that since probably since
April 2022 and I think we've probably
had around about 200 or so people from
Hong Kong coming through the course over
those uh over those uh year and a half
and for you this is quite a personal
calling too isn't it because you're off
mix British and Chinese Heritage
yourself but that it has been a
complicated Heritage in the past
yeah so uh so my dad came over from Hong
Kong to the UK to study back in the back
in the 70s he met my mum uh they got
married had a family and uh he lived
here for a little while until I was
about 10 and then my parents separated
and he went back to to Hong Kong and uh
so so I kind of was brought up without
really that that kind of Chinese or Hong
Kong Heritage uh I came come from a very
kind of white area of the of the UK come
from Shropshire so not known for its
diversity in that in that part of the
world
um so so being Chinese and wasn't a kind
of a massive part of my uh my story
growing up but in the last couple of
years it's something that I have been
discovering more about and something
that I've been uh exploring uh kind of
personally in terms of meeting family in
Hong Kong and then that is kind of
dovetailed with the with the arrival of
so many people from Hong Kong to the UK
and particularly to to the parish that I
I work in which has kind of been a kind
of a a major area that people from Hong
Kong are wanting to to move to if they
come to Leeds what I found I'm so lovely
when I talked to you earlier in the year
was how you were telling me about
practicing English with the people who
go to these well concessions but they
were teaching you Cantonese in return as
well which you know it really brings
that Heritage back um now Simon the
reason we're talking about this is
because in the last two years uh through
the British Nationals overseas passport
route the British government has allowed
uh over a hundred thousand and the
precise number is 125 000 Hong kongers
to move to the UK now you yourself are
one of those new arrivals and you had to
leave Hong Kong because of your
political activism now I know you've got
an organization here in the UK now where
you're helping the new arrival so what
can you tell us about the new Hong
kongers who are coming over you know
where do they go what sort of
backgrounds do they have what kind of uh
what kind of work do they do what kind
of people are they
yes uh thank you uh Cindy for having me
and we understand that you know this
Visa is quite comprehensive that still
opens for almost all bno Visa holders
that's the coming to the UK so it would
be a bit different from the past that's
when people hurt they immigrate into UK
either they could be more uh well
educated then stay could be more
well-off then they could come to the UK
owning uh like the job Visa or in Faster
Visa but this time that is really open
to the maths public so it really
comprehensive but generally speaking uh
this bunch of people coming to the UK
they are more living in the environment
of international City more well educated
and of course that stay would be
familiar with the UK culture so I think
this batch of the immigration will be
quite specific that they share some
historical linkage with the UK
and your organization has done a study
with the University of Liverpool I saw
which where you found that 79 of the new
arrivals are University educated many
come many come with cash from selling
their Hong Kong Flats because the
average Hong Kong flight is 1.5 million
pounds
um so they're not your usual political
refugees but Simon do you think is
politics that's mainly driving them here
I think so because that's the people
come in here for obvious reason at least
that is also the background of the Visa
policy so I guess the people that come
in here they have more concerned about
their own children's future they want to
live in a country with the academic
freedoms I think that is the most
important thing and there's a bunch of
people they also believe in their own
lie could be flourished because they
could also seek for freedom and moxies
and here perhaps a few years we develop
such a excise Community or new
communities in here and we think we're
moving to a new phase that you know
prefix that we think the migrants as a
label we need to be supportive but this
time we think we could take leads for
change we could be engaging more within
UK Society so recently I've been fun to
uh by many governments then also to
launching different types of programs to
train some we call it Community leaders
or Community organizers from Hong Kongs
to be in the UK to learn more about
what's the UK culture would be mmm
that's brilliant I mean Dave you've also
had a similar experience to that where
one of the people who was attending your
welcome session as a new arrival is now
helping you run those welcome sessions
yeah absolutely absolutely I think um so
we we cut we've kind of run two
different uh uh sessions uh two
different programs sorry and we're kind
of just on to the third program now and
uh so so actually two of the people who
who did the first session are are
helping us to to run uh the sessions now
and pretty much taking a lead in in sort
of Hosting uh and planning uh each of
our sessions uh and General
um what what are the challenges do you
see for the people that you come in
contact with Dave
um the people that are coming to your
church
um you know they they we've outlined the
ways in which they are much more you
know in many ways privileged and your
unusual new arrivals but they still have
challenges tell us about that
I think the main I mean I guess one of
the main challenges is is language we're
finding that most people from Hong Kong
have a good level of English but they
they just don't feel as confident as
they as they would like to in terms of
English so that's that's one barrier um
another one is is uh employment so lots
of people particularly people who came
uh in the first ways uh were very
successful in Hong Kong they had very
good jobs whether in whether in finance
or in other areas and what pretty much
everybody has found coming to the UK is
that they they can't work at the same
level that they they did in Hong Kong so
they uh so they're having to take uh
jobs perhaps in the same sector
um but jobs that are uh a couple of
grades down and certainly don't pay as
much as they as they as they did in Hong
Kong and some people can't get into that
into the sector that they worked in at
all so doing something completely
different but yeah that step down I
think is quite hard for a lot of people
to to kind of adjust to yeah I spoke to
a couple of people at St Barnabas Church
where you know they might have done
Property Management in Hong Kong now
they're working in a restaurant or they
might have done otherwise a white collar
job and now they're having to think
about retraining in beauty or going to a
warehouse something like that I mean
Simon presumably that's also quite
representative of the Hong Kong I see
you come across what do you think the
government can do to make things easier
well I think recently that's the
government launched a different programs
of funding for a VCS organization to
provide support and also the government
prioritize employment uh support would
be the top parity because this bunch of
the community usually have been banned
from accessing public funds except they
have been in destitution
um so that is also really important and
for giving them some confidence usually
we are experiencing some culture shocks
our academic and employment
qualification experience need to reflect
into the UK market and that is also
important that how can we start uh
easier because we have been lit off the
credit history to start even the bank
account I think it'd be quite useful to
many ethnic minority groups or migrant
groups uh just like what we are now
experiencing but also something that
might a bit unique for us that how the
eager government could give us the
Assurance of our freedoms and safety
even in the UK we know that you know the
UK China relations sometimes change from
time to time and how to make sure that
the security of the and the guarantee of
the security of our people living in
here will be intact uh would not be
harassed by any suspected informants or
agents of the CCP regime and that is
also really important topic for the UK
government
yeah absolutely Simon I mean as as we
know there is huge tension between the
Hong Kong Chinese Community here in the
UK and Mainland Chinese Community as
well do you think that the authorities
understand the nuances there you know
where a lot of Hong kongers who have
just come here often associate the
mainlanders with the CCP kind of
beijing's control and then vice versa
there's also a bit of resentment from
the other direction so do you think the
British authorities understand that kind
of complication I think there is still a
learning curve for the UK government's
the super servants to uh to to to know
the situations of the Hong Kong
Community I think the uh also major part
for us to address is about the mental
trauma we have a collective memory uh
what happens back in Hong Kong that has
like really common to see the separation
of the family disagreements among
different family members they will feel
lonely in here they would feel upset
that they are now living in freedom but
men any of their filaments and their
people maybe stay in the prison they
have a sense of guilty how can we
address this and also how can we restore
trust amongst our community members
especially as you mentioned with the
British Chinese Community will be really
important I don't think that it's only
about your own political opinion but
also under this situation especially
after the imposition of the National
Security Law in Hong Kong the threat is
also really obvious and black and white
on paper on a legal document so I think
the people they have a genuine concern
for this and that is also the people
have a concerned of they'll be left
behind when the UK government now try to
engage back with China and will that the
promise to the freedom of Hong Kong and
the human rights issues about Hong Kong
and other you know as a minority in
China will be brought back to on the
table and that will be also important to
see the attitude of the yukagne
and finally Dave weighing a moment in
public discussions in this country where
migration is a very sensitive topic you
know we've had I would say success
stories like the Ukrainian refugees and
the Hong Kong refugees coming over but
there is also a really live question at
the moment over things like the Rwanda
scheme over things like migrants from
other places the small boats crisis
how do you see the fact that you know
there has been so little backlash or
even discussion of you know the
population of Eastbourne in terms of
Hong Kong is coming over to the UK in
the last two years is it because
um they're very good at integrating and
before your experience working on the
ground what do you put that down to
um uh personally I think it seems a bit
of a hidden migration I think uh people
are kind of aware of of what's been
happening in Hong Kong over the last
couple of years and lots of people know
that Hong Kong is uh are coming to the
UK
um but I think it is very much hidden
it's kind of spread all across the
country I think other other groups of of
migrants
well there's obviously the the people
crossing in boats guess all the
headlines uh people coming from
Afghanistan uh from the evacuation a
couple of years ago it gets all the
headlines Ukraine gets a lot of the
headlines but I think Hong Kong hasn't
had the same exposure in the media that
perhaps some of the other migrations
have so I think it is in a sense quite
invisible uh you know particularly to
people who don't pay that much attention
to to maybe what's going on in Hong Kong
Simon does that wider rhetoric against
uh new migrants in general does that
worry you and the Hong kongers that you
come across yes I don't think we should
fall into the narrative that what is
good migrant or migrants because always
that you know like Hong Kong has come in
here uh we're always being framed as
pretty much well educated well-off Etc
but actually as a Association to receive
quite many cases that's actually they
need to be supported they might not be
always being living in The Stereotype of
some character people and there's much
more like more vulnerable groups that
state their voices need to be Amplified
and I think this rhetoric you know the
migrants group sometime I think uh we
need to empower uh you know that is the
same that you know the migrants that we
always see some craft people they need
some support and help and you know it is
it's really normal and usual we try to
bring it to the media and to other
people to know like you know migraines
also just the same as the local
residents and so they gonna be and they
actually they are local wrestling now in
the UK
Simon Chen and Reverend Dave ho young
thank you so much for joining us by HTV
that's it for this week once again if
you enjoy spectator TV do subscribe to
our YouTube channel just click the
Subscribe button at the bottom of this
video and tap the Bell icon so you never
miss an episode thanks again for
watching and do join us again next week
[Music]
thank you